it breaks my heart to see the people
that I love get hate and it makes me
feel so guilty that I had any part in
that whatsoever
Charlie D'Amelio getting emotional over
her drama with ex chase Hudson and
urging fans to stop sending him hate
chase and I had a very long talk
yesterday and we both realized that we
were just not right for each other and I
think that everyone involved in this
situation needs to take some time to
reflect on themselves because the fact
that we all let this go to such a big
thing and the fact that so many people's
personal lives were put on the internet
when they might not have been ready for
that to happen was not okay chase I'm
very sorry that you're getting hate you
do not deserve to be told the awful
things that people are telling you to do
and you will always hold a very very
special place in my heart this all went
down on Instagram live on Thursday after
a massive Twitter blow-up earlier this
week if you missed it things got heated
between the pair after rumors swirled
that chase allegedly cheated on Charlie
back when they were together yeah chase
admitted something went down between him
and NASA Barrett who had been dating
Josh Richards
well one everyone loves Charlie all the
guys are just gonna hate me because they
love Charlie all the girls are gonna
hate Charlie because they like me I
guess
chase addressed the situation on Twitter
throwing a ton of tik-tok stars under
the bus and then wrote in part quote the
only person who has a right to be upset
with me is Charlie and I'm sorry I hurt
her we broke up and I messed up by
kissing Nessa
Charlie responded tweeting quote stop
deflecting your actions onto others
because you can't take responsibility
chase want me to talk about how you
treated me through
our relationship or do you just want to
continue to play the victim I apologize
for what I said
I was extremely hurt and I felt the
treat
so I did what I had to do to make myself
feel better but I know that that was not
the right thing to do
and I will make sure that that does not
happen again
so here's hoping these two really can
work on their friendship and remember at
one time they were cute AF some fairy
tale right here et was with Bryce hall
last month who had a lot to say about
tick tock romances in general just like
Charlie and chases do you feel like tick
tock blew up when people started
shipping I mean I think about like even
Charlie and lo hoodie initially do you
think that was a big part in your guys's
pop one's getting big is seeing who you
guys were dating and like feels so
invested in the personal lives it was
definitely a huge factor especially
because there was like the hype of girls
and I'm the hype guys getting in
relationships it's not like a hype girl
in like a random like person it was just
like there's another huge tick-tock er I
think that like drove a lot of traffic
to it
[Music]